the Joe Rogan experience I was hanging
out on the top of I had a like when I
lived in Newton
we lived on this really steep Street and
there was a part of like above my
parents bedroom where you could stand on
the roof so you could go out to the back
you climb up a ladder you can stand on
the roof and me and my friend J Jewett
were no I'm sorry was John Jewett Jays
brother Jay was my friend too yeah John
and I were on the roof and we were
because John was dating my sister and we
were watching cars slide down this
frozen Street and slamming into curbs
every car that went down the street was
[ __ ] because they didn't know that was
it was all black ice the whole street
was black guys and we sat on the roof
and it was not a goddamn thing we could
do wait and how many black guys no not
black guys black ice 200 black guys just
watching white people Kareem and I'm
like holy gets so much better winter
weather
black ice I'm sorry I probably we've had
a lot of weed and pot and alcohol
probably black guys like it's a slam
dunk contest like cars just bouncing off
the curb and so we called the cops and
we told them hey there's all these cars
like two cars in a row have come down
this hill and they're bouncing off the
curbs and so the cops came down the hill
and they [ __ ] bounced off the curbs
these [ __ ] [ __ ] and bounced off
these curves like this [ __ ] idiot did
you not listen we called you man you got
the pho you like call Domino's they came
the same way everybody else didn't the
same thing happen like we know better we
know better we're gonna come down like
show you homos how to drive
[Laughter]
the curves but I really believe that
growing up like that is good for you I
think spending my high school years in
Massachusetts was really important it's
a really important shovel snow like that
was one of the ways we've made money
like you get pumped when it snowed out
because you could charge people see we
go to this lady's house and you know you
knew she couldn't shovel this [ __ ]
long ass driveway and you making a
negotiation like when I'm looking at it
I'll try to figure out like I'm trying
to do my math math is always terrible
valuable trade yeah like 14 I'm trying
to figure out how long it's gonna take
to dig up two feet of snow from 40 feet
of driveway hmm my daughter's price
point on that some people were great
some people were really generous they
even give you a tip you know they pay
you like you maybe $100 to do a whole
long-ass driveway but bro it would take
you all day you know when someone has
one of these [ __ ] that goes up
to their house and you got a and it's
like two feet of snow you got to do you
don't even realize how much work that is
dude that would come home wrecked just
wrecked dude we were we were at a year
at 7,000 feet in [ __ ] Idaho right and
I low on oxygen
I'm we've been riding snowmobiles
drinking beers all the way up to this
yurt and I get there in the whole
[ __ ] deck is covered there's a fire
pit I'm so excited as a Florida can I go
I'm gonna shuffle the deck and
everyone's like hey man you got a
[ __ ] heart attack and I go I go no
I'm good I'm good I'm good I've been so
excited about shoveling snow my whole
life right I've never done it it sucks
dick within I gave it to my buddy John
Sayles like oh you got a finish man I
can't do this [ __ ] I was like I'm
Florida kid man I gotta put on my
flip-flops
[Applause]